anyone want to try out an American
accent for me yeehaw howdy partner
Oh calm down there was some shootin hi
I'm Ben and right now I'm travelling
through Europe and I figured I would ask
Europeans along the way what do they
think of Americans let's go find out I
want you to be as honest as you can all
right what's the first thing that comes
to your mind when you think of Americans
[Music]
everyone says loud friendly like nice
good teeth they like to drink beer
they're nice people they like drinking
as Austrians
enthusiastic what's the first thing that
comes to mind when you think of
Americans
[Music]
superficial we like Americans they are
always quite cool they like fast food we
don't like that so much but when you are
there we enjoy it I mean the stereotypes
is like yeah kind of fad and all that
fast food they eat a lot of foods like
the portions are like really big burgers
and cooked food very fast I think a
fast-food restaurant runs five guys I
love five guys okay so if all the things
about America the one thing you can
think of just like Donald Trump in it
just everyone here not in my absolutely
loving him thank what are the - I like
the Trump we do what do you like about
Trump he's mean about the situation now
you like him because he's mean he's very
racist he doesn't really know anything
about politics when you see like
Americans you really open-minded
they're like most of them are really
smart and we can't understand that Trump
is your president I should make a lot of
you know people voted for him you get
what you're very voted for I know
everyone basically in your f is against
Trump but um I think they needed a
change I just think that the two coasts
dominated the and there's so many people
in the middle they don't get harried and
they're finally getting hurt I do like
in America that everyone's kind of if
you're born there you're American and if
you are from another country and you're
moving to Austria and your children are
born here you're still like yeah I'm
from Austria but you know my heritage is
this is that america is the land of
chance of opportunity actually I think
of the American dream
this way from the dishwasher to a
millionaire you can make everything if
you just wanted to make it and do it I
think like people look at America
they're like idolize it you know like oh
it's America yeah everyone wants to go
to America
I was pretty keen about going to America
but I think
Trump has put me off I'm not as keen to
go anymore I wouldn't be the top of my
list when I think of America I just
don't see why you need have a gun and
Poland's guns are really hard to get so
can I legal here it's not that easy to
get a gun at the far too many guns in
America of course their laws need to be
restricted and a-three hard for us to
understand because in Ireland if there
is no guns and the police ain't armed
it's just so systemic in your culture I
don't know how you could change it but
you definitely need to try
[Music]